The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Last time, we were talking
about this valence bond model
for describing the bonding.
In particular,
the bonding between atoms in a
polyatomic molecule.
And we saw that the key to this
description was allowing the
wave functions,
the individual wave functions
on an atom to constructively and
destructively interfere
themselves to form some hybrid
wave functions,
to form some hybrid orbitals.
And then it is those hybrid
wave functions that overlap with
the wave functions of another
atom to form a chemical bond.
And, in particular,
what we treated last time were
these sp^3 hybrid wave functions
that were centered on carbon,
that were centered on nitrogen,
that were centered on oxygen.
And we saw that these sp^3 wave
functions were this linear
combination, or this destructive
and constructive interference
between the s wave function and
the three 2p wave functions --
To form these sp^3 wave
functions and correspondingly
these sp^3 states.
And, as I said,
we saw that on carbon,
we saw that on nitrogen,
we saw that on oxygen.
And those wave functions end up
being pointed to the corner or
to the vertex of a tetrahedron
where the atom was at the center
of that tetrahedron.
In the case of methane then,
if you bond a hydrogen to each
one of those sp3 hybrid wave
functions, what you get is a
tetrahedral geometry around the
carbon.
If you had a nitrogen with
those sp63 wave functions around
it, and you bonded to three
hydrogens, then you got a
trigonal pyramid as the geometry
of the ammonia molecule with
those two lone pairs sticking
out there at another vertex of a
tetrahedron.
But remember we talked about
the shape of the molecule as
being described by the positions
of the atoms and not the
positions of the electrons.
And we talked about water.
Water, sp^3 hybridized.
We add two hydrogens to it.
We form two bonds that are
planar bent.
And then we have two lone pair
electrons sticking out of the
oxygen.
Those are going to play a big
role in some of the bonding
we're going to look at,
at the end of the lecture
today.
We have got to move on.
And we have got to talk about
another kind of hybridization,
which we started to talk about
last time, which is this sp^2
hybridization.
And we talked about it on
boron.
We saw that the sp^2 wave
functions end up being in a
plane which, in the case of
boron, if we then bonded
hydrogens to those sp^2 wave
functions, we got a planer
molecule for boron H three.
But carbon can also undergo
this sp^2 hybridization.
And so let's take a look at
that now.
In the case of carbon,
we have to do this electron
promotion that we talked about
also in the case of the sp^3
hybridization.
And then we let now one of the
2s wave functions and two of the
2p wave functions hybridize,
constructively and
destructively interfere.
And the result is three sp^2
wave functions or three sp^2
states with one electron in each
one of them.
And then one of those p
orbitals or those p wave
functions on the carbon is
untouched.
That is just the atomic wave
function, the atomic orbital on
that carbon.
And if we look at the picture
of all of those wave functions
here it is.
This is the 2s on the carbon,
2pz, 2px, 2py.
And what we did is let these
three, for example,
constructively and
destructively interfere to form
these three sp^2 hybrid orbitals
or hybrid wave functions.
And the result is that they
look like this.
The result is they all have a
large positive lobe on them due
to the constructive
interference,
and they all have a small
negative lobe here.
And then all of the rest of the
pictures that we are going to
draw, we are not going to draw
that small negative lobe because
it just makes it hard to draw.
But the bottom line is that
these three lobes lie in a
plane.
And then, of course,
we still had that 2py atomic
wave function centered on the
carbon.
And that is unperturbed.
Now what I am going to do is I
am going to put all of these
three wave functions on the same
plot, since they all have the
same origin.
So that is what I am doing
right there.
There it is for the carbon,
with the three positive lobes
of that sp^2 wave function all
in the same plane.
Again, I didn't draw the little
part of the negative wave
function in this picture.
But now, what we also have is
that 2py wave function,
the 2p wave function on the
carbon that hasn't hybridized.
Oh, I'm sorry.
That hasn't hybridized,
right?
And it is sticking out of the
plane of the board,
right?
That's the 2p orbital that you
are used to seeing on the
carbon.
And it is perpendicular here to
the plane in which the sp^2 wave
functions are sitting.
Now, what we are going to do is
I am going to take this sp^2
hybridized carbon,
where the positive lobes of
these sp^2 wave functions are
all 120 degrees away from each
other.
And where you would say these
wave functions had a trigonal
planar configuration.
I am going to take this sp^2
wave function,
and I am just going to rotate
it so that this lobe here is
parallel to the floor.
I am going to do that for
convenience.
And you are going to see why in
a moment.
That is what happens here on
the next slide.
I just rotated this by 90
degrees, in particular,
so I could put the z-axis here
along a bond I am going to form.
That is the top view.
Now, let's look at what this
looks like from the side.
From the side,
what it would like is something
like that.
The carbon is right here at the
center.
Then the positive lobe,
this positive part of the wave
function, that is what this is,
here.
This 2py wave function,
well, here it is.
It is perpendicular to this
plane that you are looking down
on up here.
It is perpendicular to this
plane.
That is that 2py wave function.
Positive part of the p wave
function, negative part of the p
wave function.
And then this part of the wave
function, well,
this is just a projection of
these two big positive parts of
the wave function.
This just projects this way and
out that way.
That is what it looks like from
the side.
Now what I am going to do,
is I am going to bring in
another sp^2 hybridized carbon
up here.
I am going to bring it in.
It is going to look just like
that.
Here it comes.
And when I do that,
what is going to happen right
here is that I am going to allow
the 2sp^2 wave function from
this carbon to overlap with the
2sp^2 wave function from this
carbon and I am going to form a
bond.
And that is going to be a sigma
bond, sigma because it is going
to be cylindrically symmetric
around this carbon-carbon bond
axis.
And it is a sigma bond formed
by the carbon 2sp^2 hybrid wave
function and the other carbon
2sp^2 hybrid wave function.
I have formed a bond here.
And now, what I am going to do
is bring this carbon sp^2
hybridized wave function or
carbon in again.
But I am going to bring it in
and we are going to watch this
view.
We are going to watch it from
the side.
This time, what I want you to
see is what is going to happen,
here, to the 2py wave function.
Here it goes.
We are going to bring it in.
And then this 2sp^2 is going to
form a bond here between this
carbon, but now what happens is
that those 2py wave functions
overlap.
They constructively or
destructively interfere.
If you want to watch it again,
here it comes in,
we are going to make this sigma
bond, but now these two lobes
are going to interfere and these
two lobes are going to
interfere.
And this is going to be
constructive interference there
because they both have a
positive sign or negative sign.
And so we are going to have
wave function up here and wave
function down there.
We formed another bond right
here.
The bond that we formed here is
going to be called the pi bond.
It is pi because it is not
cylindrically symmetric around
this carbon-carbon axis.
There is wave function or
electron density if you square
it up here and wave function or
it down here.
But right here,
along the plane,
there is a node in that pi wave
function.
So this is a pi wave function
made out of the atomic wave
functions on carbon.
The atomic wave functions,
the ones that haven't
participated in this
hybridization.
It is made out of carbon 2py
and carbon 2py.
What I have got here is a
double bond.
I have two bonds between the
two carbons.
I have got a sigma bond and I
have got a pi bond.
That's great.
Now let's bring in some
hydrogen.
I just did.
And when I brought in those
hydrogens, well,
you can recognize this as
ethylene.
The hydrogens form a sigma bond
between the carbon 2sp^2 hybrid
wave function and the hydrogen
1s wave function.
That is what forms this sigma
bond.
It is sigma because it is
symmetric around that
carbon-hydrogen bond access.
And the molecule that we have
here is ethylene.
Now, let's look at that again,
because this is really very
important.
Here I show you just those two
2p^2 hybridized carbons forming
that sigma bond.
And this just represents,
here, the energy levels as I
bring them in.
In this case we have two
electrons in this sp^2 state and
we have one electron in each one
of the 2py states.
And so this represents this
sigma bond here.
And then we made a pi bond.
And we will watch it now from
the top.
We made a pi bond.
We let these two 2py wave
functions overlap,
constructively interfere to
form a pi bond,
which is the carbon 2py,
carbon 2py.
Clue here, every double bond
has two bonds.
That's why it is double.
But every double bond is made
up of one sigma bond.
And the sigma bond is always
the overlap between two 2sp^2
hybrid wave functions.
And the second bond that always
makes up a double bond is a pi
bond.
The pi bond is always the
overlap of two atomic wave
functions.
In the case here of carbon it
is two 2p wave functions that
have overlapped.
That is what a double bond
always is.
It always is so whether it's a
carbon double bond or a nitrogen
double bond or an oxygen double
bond.
It is always one sigma,
one pi.
And there are the hydrogens.
And, as we said,
those hydrogens there,
that carbon-hydrogen bond is
this overlap between a carbon
2sp62 wave function and that
hydrogen 1s wave function.
And now, what is the geometry
of ethylene?
Well, the geometry here of
ethylene is that the
hydrogen-carbon-hydrogen bonds
are 120 degrees.
That is 120 degrees because
that is the result of the
hybridization,
that 2sp^2 hybridization of the
wave functions around the
carbon.
This bond here is 120 degrees,
again, because of the 2sp^2
hybridization around that
carbon.
So the geometry of this
molecule is planar.
All of these atoms are in a
plane.
Those six atoms are in a plane
and the bond angles here are all
120 degrees.
Now, if you see a carbon that
has a double bond.
If you see a nitrogen that has
a double bond.
If you see an oxygen that has a
double bond.
That is always a clue that that
carbon, that nitrogen,
that oxygen has a hybridization
of 2sp^2.
Double bonds have this
hybridization always.
If you are asked to tell what
the hybridization is around some
atom, it has a double bond to
it, it is a 2sp^2 hybrid.
Now, what I want to do is I
want to take this 2sp^2 hybrid
and build a larger molecule.
I am going to take this carbon
two, take the two carbons
here that are bonded via this
2sp^2 hydrogen.
So here are two of them.
And here are another two.
And they are kind of
strategically placed for what it
is I want to do.
And, of course,
this is the sigma bond between
the two carbons.
Here is the carbon 2sp^2 sigma
bond.
Now, what I am going to do is
bring in another carbon that is
sp^2 hybridized.
Here it comes.
And, again, it is strategically
oriented so that right here I
have now formed another sigma
bond between the carbon 2sp^2
wave function and the other
carbon 2sp^2 wave function.
The same thing right here.
I just form two other sigma
bonds.
And now, I am going to bring in
a sixth carbon,
sp^2 hybridized.
And it is going to come in from
this side.
Again, it is strategically
oriented.
I just formed,
here, another sigma bond
between these two carbons and
another sigma bond between these
two carbons.
Hey, look at this.
It is beginning to look a lot
like benzene.
[LAUGHTER]
That is my favorite part.
[APPLAUSE]
Here come the hydrogens.
This is going to be benzene.
So what did I do here?
I made some sigma bonds.
I made six sigma bonds between
the carbon 2sp^2 wave functions
and the hydrogen 1s wave
functions.
Now I've got all of my atoms
there and almost all of my
bonds.
However, we have got to do
something here about these 2p
atomic wave functions that are
centered on the carbon.
We are not done yet.
What is going to happen to
them?
Well, they are going to
overlap, constructively and
destructively interfere.
And to see that,
let's take this benzene
molecule and rotate it 90
degrees so that we are going to
look at it from the side-on view
instead of the top view.
So there it is.
Here are my carbon-carbon sigma
bonds, the 2sp^2-2sp^2 bonds.
Here is my sigma bond between
the hydrogen and the carbon
2sp^2 wave function.
And now I am going to let the
2p, the atomic wave functions,
not the hybrid wave function on
the carbon, the atomic wave
functions on the carbon,
I am going to let them
constructively and destructively
interfere.
And here it goes.
Well, they are going to
overlap.
And I've got something that
looks like a pi bond here.
I have wave function above the
plane of these atoms,
and I have wave function below
the plane of these atoms.
It is a pi bond that is formed
by the overlap of the 2p wave
functions, the atomic wave
functions on carbon.
It is pi because it is not
symmetric around,
now, the bond axis.
There is density up here,
density up there,
but not in the plane.
Let's look at it again from the
top view.
What did I do?
Well, I let these 2p wave
functions here overlap.
Let's look at that a little
more carefully.
What exactly did I do here?
Well, what I did is,
for example,
I let the 2p wave functions on
these two carbons overlap to
form a pi bond.
I let the 2p wave functions on
these two carbons overlap to
form a pi bond.
And I let these two 2p wave
functions overlap to form a pi
bond.
Well, that is very nice,
but I could also have let the
2p wave functions on these two
carbons overlap or these two
carbons.
In other words,
I could have made a pi bond
between these two carbons or
these two carbons or these two
carbons.
So which one do I choose?
Well, in recitation the other
day, you should have looked at
the Lewis structure of molecular
benzene or benzene.
And what you should have seen
is that you would be able to
write several different Lewis
structures, all which have the
same set of formal charges.
And that you wouldn't be able
to decide which structure you
should have based on the formal
charges.
Rather, what you had was a
resonance structure.
And that is exactly what you
have.
Instead of these six extra
electrons, which are centered on
the carbon, those 2p electrons,
there is one here,
one there, one there,
one there.
Instead of each one of those
electrons being shared between
just one of the adjacent
carbons, those six extra
electrons are actually
delocalized around all of the
carbons.
And so what you are going to
form here is not a clear double
bond between this carbon and
this one and this one.
Instead, what you are going to
form is kind of a half of a pi
bond.
That is, you are going to let
those six electrons be equally
distributed, so to speak,
around all of the six carbons.
And so this pi bond here isn't
quite a full pi bond.
It is kind of half of a pi
bond.
Because this carbon is sharing
its 2p electron with this carbon
and with this carbon,
and vice versa all the way
around.
And so we have this resonance
structure.
I drew this as kind of a fuzzy
green line there.
We have these six pi electrons
that are delocalized amongst the
six atoms of this carbon ring.
So these double bonds here are
really a bond and a half.
This bond is more than a single
bond in terms of its bond
strength and in terms of its
distance.
It is closer than a single
bond, but it isn't as strong as
a double bond,
nor is it as short as a double
bond.
It is somewhere in between.
That is the structure here of
benzene.
So that takes care of sp^2
hybridization.
Now, we've got one other kind
of motif and that is called sp
hybridization.
And we are going to use carbon
again as the example of this sp
hybridization.
Again, since we are starting
with carbon here,
we are going to have to undergo
this electron promotion process.
We are going to take an s
electron.
Are there some questions here
that I can help you with?
No.
OK.
We are going to take that s
electron and promote it to the
2p state.
And then we are going to do a
hybridization,
but this time,
what we are going to do is let
the 2s atomic wave function
hybridize with one of the 2p
wave functions.
And the result,
then, is that we are going to
have a new wave function that we
are going to call sp,
and there is only going to be
two of them, because we only let
one of the 2s and one of the
2p's constructively or
destructively interfere.
So we are going to get two sp
states or two new sp wave
functions.
Each one has got an electron in
it.
Each state has got an electron
in it.
And then we've got left over
two atomic states centered on
the carbon, the py and the px.
Each one has an electron in it.
Yes?
Well, by convention here yes.
The p state we are going to
hybridize is going to be 2pz,
and that is because that is the
wave function I am going to make
a bond to.
And I want that along the
internuclear axis.
In real life you cannot tell
what is x, y or z,
but by convention we are always
going to put the z-axis along
the bond axis.
And I will say a little more
about labeling py and pz and an
example that I am going to do in
a few minutes,
so I hope that will clear
things up.
In the picture form,
here are our three atomic wave
functions again.
And I am going to let these two
constructively and destructively
interfere.
And the result is,
then, two new sp wave
functions.
Now, given that I am letting
only two wave functions
constructively and destructively
interfere, it is a little bit
easier to see how I get these
shapes.
Here it goes.
This 2s wave function,
remember the 2s wave function
always has one sign?
Say it has a plus sign,
it never crosses the axis.
There are no nodes,
right?
No radial nodes.
When you have a node,
that is when the wave function
changes sign.
I am going to put that 2s wave
function in the same place in
space as this 2pz wave function.
When I do that,
since this is a wave,
it is going to constructively
and destructively interfere.
Up here, where I am
constructively interfering this
positive wave function with the
positive part of the 2pz wave
function, I am going to get a
lot of positive wave function.
That is where this lobe comes
from.
But down here,
where this is positive and this
is negative, that is going to be
destructive interference.
And because this negative part
of the 2pz lobe is actually
larger than the 2s that is
positive, well,
I am going to have a little bit
of leftover of a negative wave
function.
Here, it is easier to see how
you get this shape by the
interference of that wave
function with that wave
function.
And then, correspondingly,
I am going to let this wave
function and that wave function
destructively interfere.
If this is still positive,
positive minus a positive is
going to give me a little bit of
a wave function and it is going
to be negative.
And then positive minus a
negative, that is going to give
me a positive.
Here is my big positive part of
the wave function.
That is a little bit easier to
see, now, than in the sp^3 case,
where it is not so easy to see.
These are now my two new 2p
wave functions.
And the atomic wave functions
here, I haven't done anything to
them.
Now, I am going to put these
wave functions all on one plot.
They all have the same origin.
It is the carbon right in the
center.
I am going to put them all on
one plot.
Here they are.
And, what I did is that I
rotated the z-axis.
It was going up and down here.
The z-axis in this picture is
coming this way.
It is parallel to the floor.
Again, strategically placed for
the next bond formation.
But here, you can see the 2px
wave function,
the atomic wave function,
untouched.
And perpendicular to it,
you can see the 2py wave
function, untouched.
Now I am going to take another
sp carbon wave function and
bring it in, and I am going to
let the sp wave functions on the
two carbons overlap,
so that I form a sigma bond.
Sigma formed by the carbon 2sp,
carbon 2sp.
That's my sigma bond there.
But now, you know what is going
to happen?
We are going to let the atomic
wave functions on the two
carbons constructively and
destructively interfere.
Oh, I am going to bring in
hydrogens first.
Sorry.
We brought in the hydrogen and
formed this sigma bond between
the carbon 2sp wave function and
the hydrogen 1s wave function.
And we've got acetylene.
Except now we've got to let the
2p atomic wave functions on each
carbon interfere.
Except I wanted to point out
this geometry.
[LAUGHTER] I got this all
wrong.
This is 180 degrees because the
sp wave functions lie in a line.
The
hydrogen-carbon-carbon-hydrogen
here, that bond angle is 180
degrees.
We have a linear molecule.
And now, we are going to let
the 2p wave functions interfere.
When we did that,
we are going to form a pi bond.
The interference of this 2py
and this 2py is going to be a pi
bond.
It is pi because it is not
cylindrically symmetric around
this carbon-carbon bond axis.
There is electron density above
the plane of the slide and below
the plane of the slide.
We've got a pi bond here.
And then, finally,
we are going to let these two
atomic wave functions
constructively and destructively
interfere, the 2px.
Again, we are going to form a
pi bond.
It is pi because it is not
cylindrically symmetric around
the bond axis.
There is electron density up
here and electron density up
there.
What we have here is a triple
bond.
We have, between the two
carbons, one sigma bond,
one pi bond and another pi
bond.
The two pi bonds are
perpendicular to each other.
That is important.
So a triple bond is always
composed of one sigma bond and
two pi bonds.
That is the case,
whether you're looking at a
triple bond on carbon or
nitrogen or anything else,
well, almost anything else that
forms a triple bond.
But, for your intents and
purposes, carbon and nitrogen
are going to form a triple bond.
That is important here.
Those are our hybridization
schemes that we are going to
look at.
And it is going to allow us to
describe the bonding in lots and
lots of molecules.
And one of the molecules that I
want to describe the bonding of
is this molecule.
It is methyl nitrate.
This is going to help you out
on the homework here.
Suppose you are asked to
describe the bonding in methyl
nitrate, and you are given this
structure.
Well, the first thing you have
to do is write down a skeletal
structure, and to actually,
in your mind,
get down what the Lewis
structure is for methyl nitrate.
A couple of days ago I told you
that when you see a CH three
species like that,
it is a methyl group.
That is always terminal.
That is a carbon with three
hydrogens bond to it.
And so that is what we are
going to do.
We are going to make this
carbon there with the three
hydrogens bound to it.
And then, if you have a long
molecule like this,
one place to start is to then
just bind this atom to the next
atom.
So I did that.
I put the carbon bound to the
oxygen.
And then following that rule,
I took the oxygen and bound it
to the nitrogen.
And then following that rule,
I got two oxygens here and I
put the oxygen on this nitrogen
and the oxygen on that oxygen.
And then I drew the Lewis
structure.
I counted my electrons,
drew it up and there it is.
There is a Lewis structure.
But now what I am going to do
is calculate the formal charge.
All of these atoms here,
if I do it right,
have a zero formal charge.
I then find a formal charge of
plus one on the oxygen and minus
one on the nitrogen.
And I see that the sum of the
formal charges is zero.
And the overall charge on that
molecule is zero,
so it looks like I did
everything right.
However, is this the correct
Lewis structure for methyl
nitrate?
No.
It is not the correct structure
for methyl nitrate.
And it isn't because we have a
negative formal charge on the
nitrogen and a positive on the
oxygen, and oxygen is more
electronegative than nitrogen,
so this is not an adequate
structure for methyl nitrate.
This does not describe the
chemical bonding in methyl
nitrate.
What does?
Well, to do that let's look at
the board here.
Let's look at the bonding,
here, in methyl nitrate.
Here is another Lewis structure
that I could draw.
CH three,
oxygen, and then I could have
put the double bond here between
the oxygen and the nitrogen,
and then I could have bonded
the two oxygens to that
nitrogen.
And there is a bunch of lone
pairs here on the oxygen.
That's all OK.
But now, if I go and calculate
the formal charges on that,
I am going to get a plus one on
this oxygen.
that nitrogen,
and I am going to get a minus
one on this oxygen and minus one
on that oxygen.
That is a lot of distribution
of charge, here,
away from the distribution of
charge in the isolated atom.
Let's see if we can do a little
better.
Again, starting with the methyl
group here at the end,
let's do this.
Let us bond the oxygen to the
carbon, and then singly bond
that nitrogen to the oxygen,
and then doubly bond one
oxygen, and then singly bond the
other oxygen.
And there is going to be a
resonance structure to this
because I could have switched
where the double bonds were
here.
And if I go and I calculate the
formal charges,
I find now everything has got a
zero, except the nitrogen has a
plus one and this oxygen has a
minus one.
And that is a much better
situation than a lower energy
situation, than a plus one on
the oxygen and a minus one on
the nitrogen.
There is the resonance
structure.
I won't draw it.
But that is the Lewis structure
here for methyl nitrate.
Now, clue.
If you see an NO two
written like that,
that is always going to mean
the two oxygens are bound to the
nitrogen.
And if you ever see the word
nitrate like in that expression,
that means all of those oxygens
are going to be bound to the
nitrogen in some way.
On an exam, if you see an NO
two, those two oxygens
are going to be bound to the
nitrogen.
If you see the word nitrate,
the three oxygens are going to
be bound to the nitrogen.
Yes?
If I do that then I am going to
have these five bonds to the
nitrogen, and that is going to
give a very high formal charge.
It is not going to be the
lowest energy structure.
That is our structure.
But now the question is how to
describe the bonding in this
molecule.
Let's do that.
Let's describe that bonding.
Let me erase this structure
here.
What do we have?
We have three carbon-hydrogen
bonds.
And this carbon here is bonded
to four different atoms.
That carbon has no double bond,
has no triple bond.
If it is bound to four
different atoms and it has just
single bonds,
the carbon is always sp^3
hybridized.
That is something to know.
What that means is that these
carbon-hydrogen bonds are sigma
bonds.
They are sigma bonds formed
between the carbon and the 2sp^3
wave function and the hydrogen
1s wave function.
That describes the bonding in
the carbon-hydrogen bonds.
What about this bond,
the carbon-oxygen bond here?
How do we describe it?
Well, we already said this
carbon is sp^3 hybridized.
And so, we can write this
carbon as sp^3.
And then, this oxygen here,
well, this oxygen has got two
bonds to it.
It has no double bonds,
no triple bonds,
so this oxygen is also sp^3
hybridized.
This oxygen looks like the
oxygen in water.
This is going to be a sigma
bond.
It is going to be symmetric
around that axis between carbon
2sp^3 and oxygen 2sp^3.
We've got that bond.
Next we have an oxygen-nitrogen
bond.
How do we describe the
oxygen-nitrogen bond?
Well, the oxygen,
we already said was 2sp^3
hybridized.
We know that.
But this nitrogen has got a
double bond to it.
If it has a double bond to it,
well, that nitrogen is 2sp^2
hybridized.
But this is still a single bond
between the oxygen and the
nitrogen there.
It is symmetric.
And so that bond is a sigma
between the nitrogen 2sp^2 wave
function and the oxygen 2sp^3.
Next the nitrogen-oxygen double
bond, how are we going to
describe that?
Well, it is a double bond.
It means we have two bonds.
One of those bonds is a sigma
bond, as I said.
It is going to be a sigma bond
between the nitrogen 2sp^2 wave
function and the oxygen 2sp^2
wave function.
Because oxygen here is also
double bonded.
If we use that rule,
we will consider the oxygen to
be 2sp^2.
It is a sigma bond.
But now we have two bonds,
so the second one has to be a
double bond.
What is that double bond going
to be?
Well, it is going to be between
the nitrogen 2p wave function.
Because the pi bonds are always
between the unhybridized wave
functions.
Notice, I am going to leave out
the x or the y here,
because I don't really know.
And, between the oxygen 2p wave
function, I left out the x and
the y there.
Then, finally,
I have the nitrogen-oxygen
bond, that second
nitrogen-oxygen bond.
And, what do I have there?
Well, it's a single bond.
It is going to be sigma.
It is symmetric around the
axis.
It is going to be between the
nitrogen 2sp^2 wave function and
the oxygen 2pz wave function.
It is going to be 2pz in that
case because we are here along
the bond axis.
It is sigma bond.
It is not a pi bond.
The sigma bonds are along the
bond axis.
So that is methyl nitrate.
I am a little bit rushing to do
something here,
and that is I want to describe
to you one other kind of
bonding.
But this is a bonding that is
not a bonding within the
molecule.
It is actually bonding between
molecules.
And this is called hydrogen
bonding.
In hydrogen bonding,
what you have to have is a
hydrogen, and you have to have a
hydrogen bonded to an
electronegative element like
oxygen.
A good example is water.
Water is bound to an
electronegative element,
and we've got two lone pairs.
But in hydrogen bonding you've
got bonds between molecules.
This is intermolecular bonding.
And what happens is that this
hydrogen here will interact very
strongly with the lone pair
electrons here on its
neighboring oxygen,
forming a bond.
It does so because this
hydrogen is kind of deshielded.
The oxygen, being so
electronegative,
it has kind of pulled all the
charge toward it.
This hydrogen kind of looks a
little bit positively charged,
delta plus where this is kind
of delta minus.
And so this hydrogen being
really small,
it can get close to the oxygen
lone pairs, where there is a lot
of electron density,
and form a bond.
And that bond ranges from 20 to
60 kilojoules per mole.
Certainly not as strong as a
covalent bond.
A C-H bond is 400 kilojoules
per mole, about the tenth of
that strength.
And it turns out to be very
important.
Hydrogen bonds determine the
properties of water.
They determine the structure of
proteins.
DNA owes its helical structure
to hydrogen bonding.
Trees stand up straight because
of hydrogen bonding in the
cellulose chains.
The strength of nylon is
determined by hydrogen bonding.
And whether or not you have a
bad hair day is determined by
hydrogen bonding.
For example,
on the slides on the side,
what you see is the protein of
hair.
This is a polypeptide.
It is a repeating unit here of
C-O, C-H, N-H,
C-O, C-H, N-H again and again
and again.
Here is another polypeptide or
another peptide strain with this
repeating unit.
Well, what happens,
when your hair is actually wet,
what happens is the hydrogens
on the nitrogen,
you can see in that chain up
there --
What happens is that they are
hydrogen bonded to water
molecules.
And you can also see in the
second chain over that the
oxygen on the carbon here is
hydrogen bonded to a water
molecule.
When your hair is wet the
actual polymers in your hair
kind of slip by each other.
However, if you then take your
hair and you put it some very
strange configuration and you
dry it, you remove these water
molecules that are hydrogen
bonded to your hair,
what happens then is that these
two chains now kind of lock into
registry.
They kind of bond together
because these water molecules
are gone here.
And so now they hydrogen bond
to each other.
The hydrogen bonds to the
oxygen on the CO and the two
chains are in registry.
And then, when you let your
form go, well,
your strands actually stay in
that registry for a little bit
until the humidity wipes that
out.
Bad hair day.
See on Friday.